hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft today we
are going to make magic I don't know how
to make magic but we're going to make
magic and the way you make magic is by
making an enchanting table and the way
you make an enchanting table is by doing
apparently I don't have the recipe but I
think that's because it takes obsidian
Oh plenty right here so let me dig up
some pieces of obsidian and I'll be
right back okay
I have died a month but I need to go
look at the recipe in here
diamond diamond enchanting tale yeah I
need a book and in order to make a book
I need paper and in order to get paper I
need sugar cane and in order to get
sugar cane I need to go get sugar cane
why is my storage never enough never
enough I swear okay I'm going to go get
sugar cane where do I get sugar cane
okay you know what I'm just gonna go in
the direction and when I find it I wore
hat - all right I'm gonna find it and
when I come back you will know I found
it because I will be back hey pumpkin I
like pumpkin pork and pumpkin I don't
know what tools do you use to make
anything yeah that seems right extra
yeah Oh stogie oh jeez that's okay hey
doggies I'll come to you later I need
paper you guys found paper anywhere why
am I looking in the woods it's by water
I'm dumb I should have been following
the river I'm dumb I'm dumb guys guys
I'm dumb I'm dumb
I'm starting to realize I might be
Dumber I might actually be dumb Oh River
Oh weird mysterious whole peculiar oh
I'm gonna need experience oh if I'm
gonna be able to make enchantments it's
still something very satisfying about
just mining stuff it's really relaxing
it's really nice here we go this whoo
what that's not as deep ah my dudes
where is the sugarcane my dudes my bros
my dude bros my fam my bro fam broham
fam broham fam where is the sugar cam
bro Bellamy's oh my god the river ends I
am never gonna be able to find my way
back home there's literally no way I
would ever be able to find my way back
home I would have to be some kind of a
genius of navigation to be able to do
that if a fish can take a sword strike
that's a tough fish you gotta admit
that's a tough fish scrunch punch me
this is legitimately all it's gonna give
me that's okay it's alright I can grow
more that's the beautiful thing about
your game is that you can always grow
more and that's exactly thanks Cal Kyle
[Music]
that is a dead cow alright Cal you owe
me you're welcome Cal helped you I think
oh well I was hoping that was actually
gonna be food not just oh I probably
just eating the pumpkin straight up here
be a big B look at that big
it's almost night I forgot that it's
actually dangerous I need to get back
get out of here get out of here
I'll just gonna farm up your XP because
that's what I need for the enchanting
table oh how do I get home how do I get
home lick C and make this really
dramatic how do I get home from the US
[Music]
I'm like a baby in the woods
please won't somebody mercy on me
actually oh wait hang on no stop it was
all a joke no no no no no all right give
me home forgive me home give me my bed
give me my bed I see you I see you I see
you're gonna shoot me please I need home
I'm out of food i how do I run out of
food so quick I don't understand I
thought I was eating a lot of berries
and I'm home like nothing was ever
actually a problem I'm not quite in my
room yet this is fire spreading like the
fire spreading this a little bit and I'm
home baby
yeah easy peasy like it was nothing to
new is gonna be nothing all right
okay paper
what about book leather leather where's
a gosh-darn pig hey where'd the piggy
piggy there's you go you don't have
leather do you now get over saying that
that's what you get that's a dog I would
never kill a dog for its leather the cow
the cow that I trapped that has leather
I bet if I kill that cow okay I thought
I was gonna eat those sheep you wouldn't
have leather sheep but just in case
you never know they might have changed
the game a bit nope no leather cow does
it pick out leather I don't think so but
I'm gonna kill it anyway
nil boom nope oh I almost died to a bush
I almost died to a bush I have one heart
why am I out in the wilderness with one
heart that's a terrible idea
no I need that no don't plant I will
plant berry bushes later but don't move
like my goodness just let me live cow
where is it cow there's a gust our cow
stopped planting why am I not healing
why am I not healing
shouldn't I be healing I feel like I
should be healing but I'm not that's the
thing I'm not healing I feel feel like I
should be healing and yet stop and look
up in the sky every time I eat a berry
oh maybe it's just cuz the berries
aren't very filling oh where did I say
that cast so far back if I didn't know
and I would never save the coward would
have killed the cow I want to kill that
cow a second I could have planned the
sugarcane and by the time I got back it
would add some our sugarcane where'd it
go there's over here somewhere right it
better stow you thought you could escape
you could not leather man I think they
changed up like health recovery because
the health recovery is way slower than I
remember it being which makes it a
little more dangerous
it makes food a little more important
which is good because food wasn't very
important before but at the same time
makes it a little more set up a bunny
wunny
little bunny foo foo hopping through the
forest you got any leather leather I
don't know if I'm gonna need more
leather but just in case leather you
worked there were tons of cows oh my
goodness there were so many cows
and now there are none cuz I killed them
all am i evil
or am I just trying to survive
maybe I don't need to kill cows maybe I
don't need to enchant maybe I should let
bygones be bygones maybe I should just
make peace make peace Skyblock maybe I
should just learn to live in harmony
with the land maybe trying to change it
for my own purposes it's slowly killing
it and more importantly killing my soul
in return
hey there's my home it's on fire alright
I forgot that I was literally next to a
living portal to Hell and here lies a
stupid squid that couldn't figure out
how to water all right long long and
winding road just to get a book good
golly
alright look look look
got it ladies and gentlemen oh look
she'll fainting table oh I thought there
was gonna be a bit more fanfare but
cover my house is real horrible my house
is powerful that's just so sad my house
is so sad oh well here we go BAM boom
what is that a rock is that a potato
what do I do
but here BAM Oh lapis lazuli
I need lapis lazuli okay I didn't know
that I'm going to cook some meat mostly
just because I'm tired of dealing with
the fruit okay I'm going to eat food and
I'm gonna go down imma get some lapis
lazuli it's apparently that's what I
need and they didn't know that but I'm
gonna go anyway because I have this
gigantic mind that's all mine and I'm
gonna find it maybe some more diamond
dude I should also probably build a
better way to get back up
alright lapis you get your tooshie out
you know you're dying out stop what's
that in the darkness okay dad spider
that's what it is hey stop
do not blow up now by tiny goblets happy
tiny Goblin tiny tiny goblin tiny gum ah
what the hell
this is supposed to be easy supposed to
be easy just supposed to be easy
cool no no no no no no no stop do not
kill me
do not kill me okay okay we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine now is
much more difficult than it was supposed
to be I think the problem is because I
haven't illuminated this area so there's
a lot more enemies than there should be
don't do it no no no no well you blew up
your friends so that's all that matters
I don't have any cobblestone okay what
do we got what do we got everybody what
do we got where's the lip oozy where's
leprosy boozy will lip he's ooh ah
excellent
lapis lazuli demon demon demon demon
demon demon hate oh no you don't you
guys suck oh stop demon demon where are
you coming from oh I see there's another
spawner over here that's what it is
hello oh that's not good
oh no wait no hey that's a problem oh
crap okay I'm gonna use it no not my
staff oh that's a problem
wait I didn't expect that tax to be a
problem why is this a problem why is
this happening to me
okay okay interesting interesting I
gotta use this what I got to do is
they're gonna be clever Oh it'd be
clever about this because I'm gonna make
this guy blow up and you gotta kill you
you gonna kill you guys that's what you
get and that's yeah I'll finish you off
the whole fist oh god don't don't don't
no don't don't don't
demon little demon my barb I got to get
to my oh god I don't even have the iron
oh no I gotta push him into the you
gotta be pushed into the lava that's
what I gotta do it's gotta push him into
the lava that's all I gotta do okay come
here you
what do you think you're gonna do you
think you're gonna get anything but
pushed into the lava pushed goosed there
go easy okay I gotta get to the furnaces
cuz I gotta make oh god I gotta make
gotta make this iron okay oh hey hey
these guys suck what the hell the fresh
hell is that does that help I don't know
if that helps
oh that's not bad oh that's not bad
that's better okay that's better axe is
good I don't know what this guy's about
hey bud all right well you died just as
easily so unfortunately I don't care all
right let's try that again okay
oh thank you for revealing the lapis oh
thank you mr. creeper that was awfully
nice of you my goodness that's exactly
what I was looking for
and some gold the boot whatever gold is
good for I'm sure gold probably good for
something I just don't know what it is
mama ha ha ha ha alright you know hey
this mine's pretty good not gonna say
it's mine's pretty good hey bud sorry
bud you got a die bud sorry bud this
mines pretty good I got to find another
way out of it though because I can't
climb the stupid long dumb way that I've
got so far I want like another more
efficient route
okay I'm gonna find a way up and out of
here just try to find it relatively a
point and then go even more up ok this
seems like it might be the most up and
then I'm just gonna go up honestly I
could probably build some kind of a
spiral staircase kind of thing going on
you know what I mean
maybe Oh how deep was I and I bet I'm
tunneling straight up through a mountain
and I'm gonna pop out the top of a
mountain and I'm never gonna be able to
know where the hell I am
oh ok dirt we hit dirt that's a good
sign that's good ah sweet fresh here
uh-huh
that's the good stuff where am i okay
there's the jungle I know I'm near the
jungle how am I ever gonna be able to
find that hole in the ground
I didn't even mark it did I throw my
alright
I've lost already oh I've lost it
already oh my god I didn't mark it at
all Oh
all right it's fine you know what it's
fine didn't need it gotta get back
gotta get back too much work to do too
much work to do where am I where's back
where's home I'm complete there's more
sugar cane but where am I oh good well
is that the jungle that was it
where's the jungle that I was in where
am I I don't know oh I'm scared no wait
this is bad this is very bad where I
have too much goodies on me oh no I
should just gone back the way I came why
did I try to do something weird oh no
wait oh wait what what here we are yeah
so these good evening Lucy and sensor
that why did that throw that is my
inventory full my inventories full isn't
it ok ok there we go
help the bit anyway ok I'm home I've
flooded everything alright I'm home and
I sleep I don't know if it's better to
like make a fresh pickaxe to enchant I'm
not a hundred percent sure about that so
what we have is a fresh pickaxe I don't
know what this is is that lapis that is
lapis ooh
efficiency one unbreaking or unbreaking
i don't know why is this safe or what
does it mean I don't know anything about
enchantment I don't know anything about
it why does this take three but it's a
three here and that's a four and
efficiency I don't know what the
difference unbreaking is obvious that
just means it won't break but what about
efficiency what does that mean does that
mean this go faster better
I like efficiency I'm gonna go for that
one I did it I think what did that do
can i enchant it again is it just the
one did i cheap out on the enchantment
what's seven
we wait for the wizard well what's the
difference
wait no but I hang on but you're not
telling me what the difference is is
there no difference did I just waste
something what about this sharpness
knock back hold on
fish faster I don't know
I'm gonna guess it's faster I've done it
I've done it everybody I've done it I've
done the enchanting I'm an enchanting
genius I'm an enchanting genius John yes
even I'm an enchanting genius there's no
one that says John you said it chanting
as I am now and here forever
always will be Oh she'll be always ambi
genius and kaboom there we have it what
happens if I put armor in blast
protection projectile protection that
seems pretty good I want that right yeah
that's pretty good I feel pretty good
about whatever that is projectile
protection perfect
no projectiles will ever get me a
feather bed they're falling I fall
a lot I fall a lot that's pretty good
legs unbreaking they're already kind of
damaged that's perfect
protection and unbreaking genius is what
I am and a genius I shall remain there's
no need to thank me or applaud but you
will anyway I know thank you for
celebrating my journey Institute unless
I'm doing something wrong and then it is
simply a test and you must understand
that I am trying that if you call me out
on anything it's it's a test and if
you'd call me out you fail so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
let me know anything I'm missing in the
comments below let me know you think
down becomes below as well and as always
see you
in the next video mahir
[Music]